hey what's up guys and welcome to the
old hunters DLC it's finally here I
think I've played through about a
quarter of it so far and I just want to
share that hunt with you new weapons new
bosses new NPCs and hopefully a new
understanding of the hunters who were
around when the hunt first began
so let's hunt through it all together
and let's see what we can find
defeat vicar Amelia and the messengers
will bring you to items first the eye of
a blood-drunk hunter the people has
collapsed here which indicates the onset
of the scourge of beasts a hunter who
goes drunk with blood is said to be
taken by the hunters nightmare destined
to wander forever engaged in an endless
nightmarish hunt no hunter can escape
this fate apparently the second item is
the old hunter Belle countless hunters
have passed through the dream but cannot
forget the thrill of the hunt
the messengers relay these thoughts and
if you ring the bell by their side then
the hunters are sure to listen for the
night of the hunt is long and unchanging
and this Belle closes the gap between
worlds with these items in your
inventory
the amygdala outside Cathedral Ward will
take you to the old hunters nightmare
but unlike the old hunters before us we
go there as a hunter who has not
completely succumbed to bloodlust that's
not what sucked us in what sucked us in
was this creature that we know is
capable of teleporting you cursed a
fiends they're children too and their
children forever true if there's an
answer for that dialogue I haven't found
it yet I don't know who it belongs to
who is this woman to place a curse upon
people and what curse is she placing we
should remember this for another episode
we arrive in a distorted version of
Cathedral Ward and its surroundings and
may be distorted is the wrong word
though to me this area strikes me as
badly remembered imagine if you had to
construct a place from memory you
wouldn't get it a hundred percent
correct would you and to me I can't
like to think that whatever hosts this
nightmare had trouble remembering the
towers in the distance so the towers
appear tilted and illogical and gaps in
memory are replaced by these rocky hills
where there should be man-made paths
instead but this world this nightmare
it's inhabited just like all the others
were you know Michael Ash's nightmare
was inhabited by the puppets that he
pulled into the nightmare with him and
also by random hunters who made their
way in as well the geography might be a
reconstruction from somebody's memory
but the people within it aren't this
nightmare is full of old hunters some of
the first people to ever fight against
the beasts in the first hunts that ever
happened hunters who according to the
eye lost themselves to bloodlust and
were pulled into a nightmare where the
hunt never ends and this shows in the
gameplay the hunters and the beasts here
are constantly fighting one another and
you can use that to your advantage the
beasts are weak compared to the hunters
but there are so many so I like to take
out the hunters while they're distracted
with the beasts and once you're done
with the hunters you can equip a torch
and deal with the beasts they'll rarely
attack you all of these hunters are
wielding weapons and wearing a guard
that isn't seen in modern-day yharnam
you'll find pieces of their equipment
throughout the early level and the old
hunter garb in particular is funny its
description details the superstitions of
the first hunters how some hunters
believed that the beastly plague crept
up the right leg so they wrapped a bit
of belt around the right leg of their
trousers some thought that bits of metal
on their gloves could ward away the
beasts blood and you get the picture
they were superstitious bunch back then
the just beast tells us that one day the
hunters disappeared drunk with blood
they would pass onto the nightmare every
last one of them I wonder what's pulling
them in regardless these hunters were
around in the first days of the hunt and
this nightmare contains people and the
places that existed when the hunt first
began and I really think that in
we'll find the answer to what started
the hunt and why on this little crop of
land we find our first new weapon which
is the Beast cutter it's like a crude
more brutal version of the threaded cane
the weapon is described as regrettably
inelegant which suggests that the
earliest hunts were clumsy and bloody
and brutal which certainly wouldn't have
helped these hunters resist the
bloodshed
perhaps the refinement of weapons wasn't
just so you could deal with beasts
efficiently it would be so you could
deal with them more cleanly
anyway the world here is full of twin
bloodstone and later bloodstone chunks
as well so if you want to choose a new
weapon to upgrade it could easily be one
of these you find in the early DLC and
the DLC continuously bombard you with
new weapons which I really like it's not
like the core game that gives you all
the cool weapons at the very end there
are some good weapons at the very start
of this DLC and you find a new one what
feels like there every 15 minutes or so
so far most of my enemies have been
humanoid not beasts or monsters so as a
result I definitely recommend the
blunderbuss over something like the
pistol I've always found that the pistol
misses too much against human enemies
like you can't report them very well so
you might want to go with the
blunderbuss and I find the blunderbuss
is better at taking out all the hunters
and if I'm making this look easy it's
because I've been through here before I
accidentally played through all of this
stage on a new game+ character and holy
[ __ ] this area in new game+ is tough
enemies have so many more hit points I
actually got up to the first boss on my
new game+ character and completely
forgot that I was in new game+ but the
first boss really reminded me of that
I still haven't beaten the first boss on
my new game+ character and I was going
to show you guys that playthrough but my
pc decided to corrupt the footage
instead so this character who is not in
new game+ is much easier by comparison
my recommendation to you guys is that if
you have a new game+ character and if
it's below level 60 like mine was don't
expect to get
the first boss without a hell of a fight
choose your character wisely and look
it's the cleric beast here comes the
boss fight right any second now okay
maybe it starts when I pick up the item
no no okay then maybe it starts when I
leave no it doesn't didn't expect that
maybe later
anyway the I pendant the cleric beast
was holding reads unlocks the surgery
altar the next weapon we find is the
boom hammer and it's waiting for you in
front of this old guy who was the guy
that shoots you when you pick up the
item in front of him I'm sure you all
remember that trap I was like you're not
gonna fool me again oh this is different
the interesting part of this weapon
reads crush the beasts then burn them
the brute simplicity of the boom hammer
was favored by hunters with an acute
distaste for beasts this was crafted by
the Powder Keg hunters one of the first
hunter groups and a lot of descriptions
do reference these groups blood-borne
already has a fairly straightforward
timeline it's not like Dark Souls which
spans hundreds or even thousands of
years Blood borns timeline seems like it
happens within a century or so in my
opinion so this DLC answers a lot of
questions about the progression through
all the different hunter groups and
their history and we even learned that
there is a group that came before the
Powder Keg hunters and it's this beastly
enemy we fight next that gives us this
information he has this enhanced beasts
hood that I've still yet to learn about
he has a way bigger moveset than the
beasts claws should give you I think
it's a rune that lets you get into the
beasts form he's in anyway he's where
the central yharnam lamp would be where
Gilbert would be if this was the real
world and he drops the firing hammer
badge which I believe unlocks the timed
Molotov cocktails that you saw being
thrown around before and also the
piercing rifle which was and I quote
developed by the auto workshop which was
the workshop that came before the powder
keg hunter workshop
you're a hunter with your sanity aren't
you must have taken a wrong turn Danae
well we're more alike than you think
this is the hunters nightmare where
hunters ender when drunk with blood
using them before aimless wandering
hunters slavering like beasts this is
what the poor fools have to look forward
to so don't be brash turn back before
it's too late
unless you've something of an interest
in nightmares yes as it should be
hunt your beasts and think no more on
the secrets of the night that is the
very best aunt I can do just don't get
the blood intoxicate you you can say no
here
you can say I'm not interested in
nightmares but then you can also talk to
him again
to give what is supposedly the right
answer which is apparently yes I am
interested in nightmares because he
stops talking to you after you say yes
what now I'll take my word and turn back
before it's too late
unless I suppose you've taken an
interest in nightmares oh yes I see you
sense a secret within the nightmare and
cannot bear to leave it be as if the
spirit Bergin worth lives on within you
such inquisitive hunters will relish the
nightmare but beware secrets are secrets
for a reason and some do not wish to see
them uncovered
especially when the secrets are
particularly unseemly this guy will
appear later and he tells us to carry on
further into the nightmare but he warns
us that some secrets aren't meant to be
found
secrets hype down the Blood River is the
Gatling gun hunter who attacks you in
the pitch-black with this brutal brutal
weapon that will stun lock you if you
stand anywhere near him I found the best
way was to rotate around this rock until
he takes a break from firing then you
get a few hits in and you rinse and
repeat his gun can't fire forever so
start your assault on him as soon as it
stops firing you actually get the
Gatling gun for defeating him it
requires blood tinge and strength so I'm
going to bet that blood-tinged strength
builds are going to be a thing now that
weapon is a beast
I really recommend using the hand
lantern in here further on you have to
fight a small bloodletting beast and
you'll actually want to see what you're
shooting at because it's important to
counter this guy with a gun in your left
hand this room holds the amygdalin arm a
gruesome little trick weapon that you
can use as a short hammer or a sinewy
scythe thing where one of the limbs just
flows around with the ligament attached
to it from is so creative with their
weapons the next two weapons is the
beast hunters safe which is way better
than I thought it would be it just looks
like a shorts or cleaver but its
simplest attacks include a lot of little
bashes and everyone knows how important
it is in souls games to quickly close
distances it's a really underestimated
weapon I think the next weapon is the
whirligig saw I love it just look at how
you can grind down an enemy by holding
l2 this weapon belongs to Valtor the
Beast eater leader of the league and
he's the old hunter you meet in the
forbidden woods if you went and joined
the league when patch 1.07 hit the
league is a co-op covenant and I'm going
to use this guy to help me in my boss
fight because I found the boss fight
really tough I haven't had much sleep so
maybe I'm just not fighting very well
but it felt good summoning this guy this
the LC is called the old hunters after
all and might as well summon one of them
right
it was nice feeling like I had a
teammate against this guy so let's fight
that next boss shall we
Oh
Hoss
I'm not going to talk too much about the
law in these videos but just quickly
ludwig was originally the first hunter
of the healing church a cleric who
became one of the most gruesome beasts
in the first phase of the fight it's
vitally important that you kind of
become familiar with his moveset and
most importantly I think you have to
learn where it's safe to hit him and
where it's safe to heal I find the best
place to be attacking is his left side
because if you get behind him he'll
bucket you like a horse if you get under
him he'll stamp around and likely kill
you and if you get in front of him he'll
do these quick little slashes that are
hard to predict and dodge inevitably you
do have to dodge through these front
facing dashes and that's what's so tough
one of these dashes has a really long
wind up that will catch you if you dodge
too early but you have to dodge early
against most of his dashes because they
will combo you if you just take the hit
so it's a tough fight because of that
you can't dodge too early and you can't
dodge too late your reflexes have to be
on point if you're soloing this guy
which is why I brought Volta in I
decided that this companion hunter was
going to be my wind condition he's
fantastic for distracting Ludwig but he
only has a limited amount of blood
vessels so once he's healed like five
times he'll stop healing and the boss
will kill him and you'll be in trouble
so like I said my wind condition was to
keep him alive I brought the choir bell
along with me and I kept healing Valtor
whenever he got low so basically I was
keeping my tank alive I'd never fought a
fight like that in blood-borne before so
this was really fun for me and I really
wanted this NPC for Phase two of this
fight
ah you were at my side all along my true
mentor
my guiding moonlight
this is awesome that music transition is
so seamless and epic all of a sudden
moonlight greatsword out of nowhere but
if you did look closely you would have
noticed that Ludwig actually had this
moonlight greatsword strapped to his
back all along it's fairly easy to dodge
the swipes from this great sword if he
starts doing slam attacks you dodge
early and if he starts swiping Hugh
dodged through the attacks and during
this fight you'll have two chances to
repost him to perform visceral attacks
and it took me a while to figure out
where to perform the visceral attack but
eventually I realized you have to go
right up to his crotch and yeah the
easiest way to die in this fight is if
you get caught in his huge charged of
moonlight wave attack he does this quick
a away to make you dodge backwards but
then he follows it up with his slam down
that creates this giant wave of
moonlight energy that just destroys you
look how devastating it is so you've got
to dodge away from the initial AOE and
then you've got to get right back close
to him again so you can dodge that
attack but eventually I succeeded
good hunter have you seen the thread of
light just a hair a fleeting thing yet I
clung to it
steeped as I was in the stench of blood
and beasts I never wanted to know what
it really was really I didn't a tragic
figure but he will shame himself no
longer he died with his ideals
untarnished he was a true hero and
earned that much at least do you know
why doctors are drawn to this nightmare
because it sprouted from their very
misdeeds things that some would rather
keep secret a pitiful tale of petty
arrogance really high time someone
exposed the whole show wrong